[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in kurt warner hall of famer
got a movie out called american underdog
apparently acting like a hollywood star
shows up late so
typical hey hollywood how are you
what's going on my man i apologize uh
apologize lots going on
my time is mixed up so i apologize for
that do you have final say-so in that
movie final approval
yeah i wouldn't say final say but
definitely had to say it was a
collaborative effort um
you know we got to uh everything from
writing the script to uh to being on set
and doing some of the different scenes
uh we had a lot of input uh but at the
same time we had a good team that uh at
times sat back and said nope that's a
bad idea we're not we're not gonna
listen to that one so um
they probably helped us from screwing up
the movie trying to get some of the
stuff that we wanted in it uh but a
great team and we're excited about this
movie and everybody get a chance to see
it
i'll uh give the full introduction based
on the true story of kurt warner
american underdog in theaters everywhere
on christmas day also on christmas day
uh kurt's working uh he'll be uh calling
the colts and the cardinals kick off at
8 15 eastern exclusively on nfl network
are you in the movie
um there's a couple what they call
easter eggs in the movie that uh may be
able to keep an eye on and see if uh see
if you can find me and my wife
easter eggs
yes that's what that's what they like to
call it when they give uh you know
individuals little cameos or throw them
in little spots in the background um in
the movie so there's there's a couple
little things in the movie
did you have approval on zach levi
who plays you
no i had no approval when it came to the
casting uh left that up to people that
are much smarter than me but uh
zach does a great job you know i think
when you think about the casting you're
always thinking about okay does he look
like me
um is the most important thing and
obviously zach looks like me but it
really comes down to what they do
on the big screen and zach and
anna i thought did a great job of uh you
know playing myself and my wife in this
movie all right you're going to call the
cardinals and the colts which team do
you have a better idea of who they are
right now
um i'm probably going to say the colts
um as as amazing as that might be
the cardinals being the number one seed
just a couple weeks ago
uh they're just not playing very well on
either side of the ball and not playing
great offensively which was really their
calling card with the way kyle was
playing early in the year and the colts
even though i think he got some
questions about the quarterback position
and what uh carson weds can be
in that moment and down the stretch what
you know about them is they're going to
play great defense and they're going to
run the football and you know you're
going to get that every time out so i
would probably say i have a better feel
for what the colts are right now than
the cardinals
yeah i i'm not ready to christen the
cardinals as you know one of those
favorites for the nfc they they can have
a nice record but i i just want to see
them
in a big moment um
and and i just don't know there's a
couple of those teams though kurt when
you think about it i don't know what
tampa is going to be like at the end of
the season
i don't know what the cardinals going to
be like i don't know is dallas
consistent enough
um
and and the rams too you know you just
there's a lot of teams where you're just
not sure how good they can be can you
win back-to-back games can you win on
the road
out of those teams which one do you like
the best
well i mean i think i still lean towards
tampa simply because of tom brady and we
know what we're going to get from him
in the moment i i think that becomes the
question for me is you know it's so much
about the quarterback when you get to
the playoffs and can that quarterback
put together a consistent run
of three or four games because that's
what it takes to win a championship and
yes you win championships as a team but
you have to have good play at that
position and the teams that you
mentioned probably outside of tampa or
the teams that you say
okay we've seen those quarterbacks play
great in moments we've seen them play at
mvp level
but do we know that we're gonna get that
every single time they show up in the
playoffs and that remains the question
for me as well as
as good as i think you know
all those teams that you mentioned can
beat anybody on any given sunday no
question
can they do it three or four straight
times
four rookies made the pro bowl if you
were drafting
micah parsons jamar chase kyle pitts
rashaan slater
um
uh well i mean you probably gotta go
micah parsons uh he's been such a
difference maker sean slater i think
it's been great too and
knowing how important a left tackle is
um you know building around a guy like
that can definitely see it
but micah has been so good and so
dominant so quickly can do so many
different things
i just i probably go that direction
knowing what we
know now and knowing what his ability is
as a pass rusher uh and as a linebacker
probably lead that direction but rashaan
slater is probably
right behind him
you had that moment of frustration for
brady against the saints where he's
talking to the saints sidelines you ever
do that when you play
um
not too often not too often try to try
to never let somebody you know feel like
they
got the best of me or i was doing
something
out of character uh if it ever happened
it was probably more on my sideline
where i got into it with my coaches or
another player on my sideline more than
i did it to the other team because i
think once you start to get out of
character the other team goes uh we got
them now let's just let's continue to
ride that thing
well good luck with the movie my best to
brenda and uh we'll be watching the
colts and the cardinals that'll be
kickoff at eight eastern exclusively on
nfl network uh merry christmas to you
kurt and uh my best to the family
thank you very much uh merry christmas
to everybody there on youtube thank you
buddy that's kurt warner the movie
american underdog in theaters everywhere
on
christmas day